brandon woodruff has given up just
two earned runs in his last 25 innings
coming off a terrific month of april
yeah he has been just fabulous
you can't imagine brandon being able to
pitch any better than he has
right now they're just trying to find
something to get them going collectively
as an offense because they know
the talent is there that's that game two
off he's back in there tonight
off we go with a high drive to left
center field
milky blast right away
on the first pitch of the game a mookie
moment right away
welcome back to the lineup mookie betts
and the dodgers jump out front one
nothing
corey seeger is the better zieger hits
it hard
garcia right there and a line drive out
for the first down of the ball game
justin turner is about her now bouncing
ball to third
shaw's got time and there's out number
two for woodrow
and max muncie is coming up woodruff
deals and a slow roller woodruff an
excellent athlete makes a play
and that will retire the side this is
dustin may
a 2-5-3 era and a ton of k's
in his first four starts may's breakout
percentage is
third the national league count wong
will lead off to the corner with 99
strike three strikeout number one for
dustin
daniel vogelback left-handed batter 1-2
back-to-back case to open the game for
may opponents now oh for
22 with 15 strikeouts against that fish
garcia's in there justin turner
and 11 pitches a one two three first for
dustin man
and baby is a board with a lead off
single here's pollock
on the first pitch gotta hurry here pog
runs well maria's throws in time
double play and dustin may facing the
left-handed hitting travis shaw
swing and a miss strike three already
his third
luis suryas the shortstop right-handed
battery maria's on the first pitch that
ball's hit
and there she goes luisa
a solo shot with two outs and we are
tied at one
last three starts five of the six runs
that mays allowed have come off of home
runs
oh no dustin may wince as he let that
pitch go and then immediately wave to
the dugout
he is in serious pain right that's not
good for him
he is clenching his right hand he's not
moving his arm
and he is coming out of the game they're
not even going to discuss it so this
is alarming dave roberts kind of showing
the other pitchers what's going on
pointing at the forearm and elbow area
yeah you don't want to speculate but it
kind of had that look to it gareth
clevenger the first man in and what
will turn out to be essentially another
bullpen game for the dodgers
mckinney in a walk that belongs to me
melee with a single to right then walk
to the pitcher
a key moment early in this game as
colton long comes up with the bases
loaded i'll be moving with a pitch a 3-2
packed up center field mookie belts
garrett clevenger somehow able to escape
it with nothing crossing
runner aboard for corey seeger 1-1 in
the third
bets takes off and seeger hits a fly
ball to deep shatter bradley's back
it's off the wall bucks will score
easily
and the dodgers are back in front two
one justin turner trying to pick up
another one
oh two pitch turner just lays the bat on
it fly ball to right
had him full and garcia puts it away and
that will retire the side
two up and two are down in the brewers
half of the third inning for travis shaw
in the air right center way back
oh hits the scoreboard travis shaw
a booming home run and this game is all
tied into
jimmy nelson replaces clevenger in a 2-2
game here in the fourth
and luke maylie will be the hitter and
another swinging to miss in a breaking
ball and melee strikes out so two gone
and woodruff indeed will face jimmy for
the 1-2
inside corner to get him back-to-back to
finish off the brewers in the fourth
first and third for la with seeger
coming up oh big moment in the game
right here for brandon woodruff and
a swing at a miss he struck him out
second out from brandon woodruff his
third king
now two men are out here's justin turner
high stress pitches here for brandon
woodruff in the fifth inning
bets goes and a swing and a miss he
struck him out
wondrous takes care of business and the
dodgers strand the pair
scott alexander fourth pitcher of the
day for the dodgers
brews trying to take advantage of the
two out walk
lifted the other way routine for pollock
and another scoreless outing for scott
alexander
well again woodruff having to make some
high-stress pitches here with a runner
and scoring position
go ahead and run at third one and two
the count with two outs
a swing and a miss he struck him out
and the go-ahead run or the second
straight inning left at third
dennis santana comes on the pitch second
and third
two outs in the inning the rookie tyrone
taylor with a chance
to do some damage
[Applause]
that kills the brewer threat wong gets
himself a lead off base hit
the pitch outside runner goes throw down
muncie's got him oh what a throw by
austin barnes oh my goodness what what a
play by austin barnes that was
incredible
juan immediately points towards his
dugout and says have a look
oh i think his hand was in there rode
yeah he's safe you're right he doesn't
get the arm oh my goodness he's kidding
how is the call oh my goodness i even
have replay
you butcher a call like that that's
terrible
kentley janssen who has not pitched
since monday comes on as the seventh
pitcher today
and there is the go ahead run at first
in the eighth inning well what a spot
for luke maley huh
first start as a brewery
let's go to the ninth inning in
milwaukee josh hayder on the mounds his
third consecutive day
on the bound for the brewers this year
so will smith pinch hitting
with the go ahead run in scoring
position and two gone here in the night
and he hoists one in the air that'll get
him out of the inning
jackie bradley jr calls and josh hader
puts up a zero in the night two on and
one out and with justin turner on his
way to the plate this is who you want up
gotta find a way turner right center
field base hit dodgers lead
will smith in the score and an rbi
signal from justin turner
the brewers are gonna walk muncie here
and it's going to be clayton kershaw who
will get it out back
out and the base is loaded the one-two
pitch
and a swing and a miss he got him aj
pollock coming to the plate
rasmussen deals bouncing ball he's got
it
nice play he doesn't make that play
that's probably a hit
inning is over alex vicia makes his
dodger debut
bases are loaded now it's up to luis
urias for some magic here tonight the
2-0 and a swing and a papa
a sacrifice fly and this game is all
tied at three
first and second and one out this will
bring up will smith
dodgers have had so many opportunities
today with runners in scoring position
swatted down
[Music]
[Applause]
the bases are loaded and nobody out for
the brewers
colton wong will face mitchell white
it's a sac fly from colt
long by four dodgers avisael garcia
and now the brewers down to their last
out and the brewers down to their last
strike
[Applause]
garcia
[Applause]
right under his glove we are tied at
five
four times the brewers have come back
travis shaw's gonna end it
no balls two strikes shaw right field
down
base hit feliciano around third that's
his throw
and it's over the brewers win
travis shaw wins it for milwaukee